we're going to be talking about kissing
numbers which is perhaps less exciting
than it sounds it sounds like we're
taking the name of the channel a bit too
far
kissing numbers is it's actually about
how many spheres we can fit around a
central sphere it comes from billiards
so when two billiards make contact they
kiss and this actually was the source of
a disagreement between two
mathematicians a guy called Isaac Newton
I don't know if you've heard of him and
a guy called David Gregory and they
disagreed how many Spears you could fit
around a central sphere so David Gregory
went to Isaac Newton because he's the
he's the guy right they were talking
about planets and how they move around
and then they went off topic and Newton
said you can fit 12 spheres around a
central sphere David Gregory thought no
actually I think possibly you might be
able to fit 13 fit one more in if you
look at the traditional hexagonal
packing this would be twelve spheres
around the central sphere so you got the
central sphere here you got six going
around the equator you would have three
at the top and three below it which
means you have twelve spheres fitting
around the central sphere and if you
extend that forever
that's the hexagonal packing and that's
rigid as well it doesn't seem possible
that you can fit in any extra spheres
into that structure well actually that's
not the only way our fitting spheres
around the central sphere another
possibility would be something more like
the spots on a football I said I was
going to hope it I had it there it
wasn't so imagine we put the spheres
exactly where the spots are on this
football so there'd be one at the top
would be one at the bottom and then we'd
have a row of five around the top and
another row of five round here at the
bottom so I've got a prop here so it's
made out of bouncing balls and cocktail
sticks kind of like the football I was
trying to fit spheres around the central
sphere but can you see if I do that
there were massive gaps I don't even I
can turn it over find any other massive
gaps no could see another massive gap
here perhaps if we bunch up these
spheres these gaps will be big enough to
fit in at an extra one so that was the
problem so let's see who was correct
you can think Newton all right let's
have a look so it's not obvious what is
the correct answer let me show you why
you might think it's 13 imagine I
contained this prop I've made in another
sphere so if these had radius 1 then the
big sphere that's going to contain it
would have a radius of 3 and fact I'll
draw it out five six something like that
right these are Spears so imagine they
are spheres now we're going to contain
this in a larger sphere now imagine we
put a light right in the middle of this
sphere so we're going to shine a light
and we're going to cast a shadow on the
inside of the surface of the big sphere
like this so if you do the calculations
and if you look at the area that these
shadows cast there is enough space on
the inside of this massive sphere to fit
14 shadows and nearly 15 actually not
quite enough for 15 but definitely 14 so
it seems like you should be able to fit
13 perhaps that argument would work if
we're talking about circles fitting
circles within a one big circle and you
looked at the shadows then you would get
six shadows and you can fit six circles
around the central circle so it seems
like this argument suggests that you can
fit thirteen spheres maybe even 14 but
it was difficult to proof so if we want
to do it with two dimensions it's
actually not that difficult to show that
the kissing number is six and you might
be able to see you then if they weren't
any closer they would overlap so it's
not too hard to show that six is the
maximum number of circles you can fit
round here another way of saying that is
if you look at the kissing points here
like this they make an angle of 60
degrees and that's true on a sphere as
well the two kissing points will make an
angle of at least 60 degrees let me just
draw out a sphere to show you the sort
of thing I mean by that and this have a
point on the surface let's call that
point X well give it a coordinate so in
three-dimensional space it would have
coordinates record it X 1 X 2 X 3 and
let's have another kissing point on the
surface we'll call that Y couple of
things I can tell you about these points
that are on this sphere if this is a
sphere of radius
on then I can tell you with a bit of
Pythagoras but if I use the coordinates
x1 squared plus x2 squared because x3
squared is equal to the radius squared
the radius is 1 so I can say that's
equal to 1 so that's going to be true
the other thing I wanted to point out is
the angle between these kissing points
is going to be at least 60 degrees now
there's a formula for working out the
angle using the coordinates based on the
cosine of an angle so let's say the
angle is Theta that's a traditional
symbol to use so we're going to look at
the cosine of that angle theta and the
formula for that using coordinates is X
1 multiplied by Y 1 plus X 2 multiplied
by Y 2 plus X 3 multiplied by Y 3 now I
want this angle to be greater than 60
degrees that means that this cosine is
less than 1/2 and we've got these two
little formulas here surely using these
formulas this is enough information to
work out how many kissing points we have
on the sphere so you can do that I've
seen a more modern proof of this by a
mathematician called Oleg mucin and he
showed that you can have a little
function something that's based on all
the angles between the kissing points
I'll just go call it s for no reason he
showed that this thing is always greater
than or equal to the kissing number
squared and less than 13 times the
kissing number which is enough to prove
the kissing number has to be less than
13 the kissing number must be less than
13 so you can prove that is true but we
already know an example where the
kissing number is 12 so that's it
so the kissing number is 12 that must be
the maximum number that you can fit
around a central sphere so guess who was
right after all
of course Isaac Newton was right that
was a good feeling of Isaac Newton yes
so you shouldn't disagree with Isaac
Newton's
good feelings so I mentioned that I've
read a more modern proof of this by
Ehrlich mutant I he actually showed what
the kissing number would be for the next
I mention look for four-dimensional
looks fears now this is getting into
crazy areas right I can't imagine and
what a four-dimensional sphere looks
like I have no idea what that means when
when you start getting into higher
dimensions I start to rely purely on the
formulas so a formula then for a
four-dimensional sphere well remember
these are points on the surface of the
sphere and we're just going to extend
these formulas we already found for
three dimensions in four dimensions a
point that is on the surface would have
a first coordinate squared plus the
second coordinate squared plus the third
coordinate squared plus the fourth
coordinate squared would equal to the
radius squared which let's say it's
radius 1 would be 1 so I would just rely
on what those formulas mean cuz I just
can't picture what a four-dimensional
sphere would look like so but he had the
same argument so using these kind of
formulas went through the same kind of
argument and worked out the kissing
number for four-dimensional spheres had
to be less than 25 strictly less than 25
and he already knew there was an example
of 24 so there is a structure that has a
kissing number of 24 it's called the 24
cell it's in the 4 dimensional space
but we already know one that has 24 so
that's it
so the kissing number in dimension 4 is
24 for higher dimensions
5 6 7 we don't know we don't know what
the kissing numbers are but bizarrely we
do know the answer in dimensions 8 and
dimensions 24 so in dimension 8 so
imagine eight dimensional spheres the
kissing number is 240 so you would have
240 spheres around a central sphere and
in dimension 24 the kissing number is
190 6500 imagine all those spheres
around a central sphere and we know the
kissing numbers in those particular
dimensions because we have structures
that are particularly regular which
makes it easier to prove
what the kissing number is now those are
regular structures there is no reason to
believe that in higher dimensions that
the maximum kissing number is going to
be with a regular structure it's
probably going to be an irregular
structure in fact I can give you an
example of that because in dimension
nine we've shown that all the regular
structures have a kissing number that is
less than 272 but we have an example of
an irregular structure which has a
kissing number of 306 so it's higher
than all the regular structures so why
are 8 and 24 special in this when we
have these regular structures in
dimensions 8 and in dimension 24 the
gaps start to get bigger and then they
get so big that you can fit in extra
spheres into the gaps and that's true at
dimension 8 it's true at dimension 24 so
just because of that property we can
really pack in those spheres in those
particular dimensions this is the second
in a sphere trilogy of videos with dr.
Graham there are more details in the
video description and it was brought to
you by brilliant you know I think we're
all pretty familiar with how we can make
our bodies more fit we can exercise we
can go to the gym we can run but how do
you make your brain more fit how do you
improve your thinking well the great way
to do it is going along to brilliant
where they've got all sorts of puzzles
and quizzes and courses that are
specially designed to change the way you
think to make you smarter
this isn't memorizing equations these
aren't things that are going to help you
pass that next test this is about
changing the way you're wired changing
the way you attack problems
everything's beautifully designed it's
really clever there's lots of free
content on the site but you can also get
20% off a premium subscription which
unlocks all the goodies by going to
brilliant
org slash numberphile the URLs on the
screen and in the description
our thanks to brilliant for supporting
this video
you